it was a triumph of taxidermy another
big night for Joe Biden who will add to
his delegate lead over Vermont senator
Bernie Sanders with a series of wins
tonight the rest of the evening is
shaping up very nicely for Joe Biden hmm
so what did we learn America first
politics is like real estate location
location location as forceful as
Bernie's vision was it was in the wrong
place
America being a socialist in the most
successful economy in history is like
trying to sell Ben & Jerry's in Siberia
America listen to a 70 year old try to
sell a bad idea that's twice his age and
said no way and that youth vote looks
like the 50-plus crowd who pay their
bills make wiser choices surprise
meanwhile with Joe that cardboard
contraption may have structural flaws
but at least it's standing in the right
place plus he remembered his pants as
one wise man once said perhaps yesterday
on this very show Dana the Dems voting
for Biden are purchasing a teardown it's
not for the structure but the land his
VP pick may be in charge at some point
if he wins
so voting for him is like snapping up a
prime lot in which to build the Harris
home The Cove watch our Castle a Warren
wigwam which is why the Dems want to end
this thing before a debate they know
with each passing week the weaknesses of
what they're left with become more
apparent they should have blasted
Sanders radical left is Amuro on but
they kind of liked looking the look of
agreeing with him so he's going nowhere
Donald must be defeated and I will do
everything on Sunday night in the first
one-on-one debate of this campaign the
American people will have the
opportunity to see which candidate is
best positioned to accomplish that goal
I very much look forward to the debate
in Arizona with my friend Joe Biden so
the dams had two choices the radically
wrong who honestly reflects the party's
secret socialism or the conventional
codger who limp to the finish line to
deliver someone young
and knew like Hillary it could work but
if they don't get Biden prepped and
propped before Trump it'll be like
feeding old-growth logs to a wood
chipper all right Jesse Bernie staying
in huh what do you think you think
here's a conspiracy he's stayed in
because he's not sure Joe's gonna make
it to the end before the convention
right he's not gonna make it to the
convention and if he doesn't make the
convention then Bernie's gonna go who
really om everybody yeah he's hedging
his bets but just before we get into
this Greg you've fallen in love with
this teardown analogy yes I have you're
gonna use this thing every day until the
convention I'm gonna get sick of it so
just America you've been warned I do
think that abate is a big test for Joe
yeah he's a terrible debater he's
probably lost every single one of the
debates he was in yeah it is still
standing I don't think he's gonna do
one-on-one well against Bernie Sanders I
just don't and I feel bad for him and I
don't feel bad for anybody that's right
have very little empathy for any of your
coal but it's gonna be a sad situation
if he loses his temper with regular
voters how is he gonna do against Donald
Trump Trump's gonna make his head spin
Joe Biden this is not presidential
timber he's a bad communicator he's not
that sharp has poor instincts and has no
magnetic ISM the guy does not have what
it takes he's been in the Senate for 36
years mm-hmm
he was VP for eight years thinks he's
still running for this exactly the US
Senate he's passed his due date his
brother's involved with fraud charges
his son is stiffing his baby mama and
blamed it on coronavirus I love that
it's not a good look for a joke that
works out today but Bernie Bernie had
his back against the wall it didn't
throw a punch mm-hmm I mean it doesn't
look like Bernie wanted it and I think
everybody watching him knows that once
you praise communism there's no way
you're gonna beat Donald Trump black
America wet wood Joe and that was all
she wrote but if you think about it
Bernie had no chance to beat Donald
Trump Joe Biden had better than no
chance but that's still not a very good
chance so at the end of the day the only
thing you could say about Joe is he
saved his party from socialism what do
you think Nancy how do you have any
strong predictions well the reality is
that Eve
if Sanders does a horrible job excuse me
even if Biden is a horrible job against
Sanders which he will doesn't matter
because the Democrats have coalesce
congealed around buying so no matter
what happens that's what it's going to
be Trump D Biden and I've got to say
that Sanders has passion he believes it
even though it is socialism like Cuba
but I don't think Biden has any clue
about what's going to enough Jill Biden
ran that might be an entirely different
story when when she blocked you that
person Bernie shirts going after Jo Jill
can jump on stage and she is a doctor
and we need a doctor in these trying
times Juan what is your analysis well
William well it seems to me that you
know Joe Biden had a great night last
night and I think he's I don't think
there's much of a way you could conceive
of him not being the nominee at this
juncture but I do think that even though
you have the lead and the ball you can
fumble hmm or you can throw an
interception we was that I think was it
the Seattle Seahawks threw an
interception I think this happened right
but I do think that what you're saying
about Joe Biden reminds me of what you
said about Joe Biden the way back oh
he's made so many mistakes he's a stiff
he can't debate he's makes the gaffer
guess what Joe Biden is doing pretty
good but that's because feeling like the
Democratic voters are not concealing
real people went and cast their votes
that's true a decent upstanding proven
public servant and Donald Trump give us
your expertise okay so Biden I think
went to Michigan once yes he won every
single County in Michigan right and
higher margins then in 2016 the Bernie
got and I think that everybody should
look at 2016 the Democrats in their zeal
for Bernie Sanders because he has
passion and he has these ideas
they have these ideas the truth is I
don't think that the Democrats were as
far left as some of us were thinking
right they just could not stand Hillary
yeah if you look at these breakdowns the
white men voted for Bernie in 2016 no
they all went for Biden in 2020 because
they did not like the choice between
Bernie and Hillary right that is because
so then that lesson was not learned so
now you have Biden who now you have to
go to a debate to debate these ideas
with Bernie Sanders that have been
rejected across the country by Democrats
who are actually voting can I um to that
point I have some sound on tape
saw to you people at home of Bernie
talking about this jet how he's winning
the generational battle let's play that
for the heck of it and I've got we are
winning the generational debate well Joe
Biden continues to do very well with
older Americans especially those people
over 65 our campaign continues to win
the vast majority of the votes of
younger people and I am talking about
people not just in their 20s but in
their 30s and their 40s all right well
the thing is you can have a movement and
that's great
I do this whole thing about Bernie
Sanders is so amazing okay so you have
young people that come to your rallies
and they love you and they do love you I
get it and they will vote for you they
will vote for you but in these tiny
little numbers it doesn't matter if
you're not moving the needle so yeah
there are older voters they just chose
somebody else Julie the irony is is that
MTV started Rock the Vote and now those
are the older voters and they're rocking
the vote one so in fact what Bernie says
it's true he won voters 18 the 35 and
even under 45 but not by large margins
and to reiterate what Dana just said
they didn't turn out they didn't turn
out so you know he can go after trade
policy he can go after health care and a
lot of Democrats are going to agree with
him but ultimately as he said they don't
agree that he's the best ten
to beat Donald and it also hurts him
when he brings Omar on stage or AFC on
stage and you know you lose a lot of
working-class voters when you go crazy
green New Deal extreme